[Musik]
auch heuer präsentiert sich das
österreichische bundesheer in wien zum
nationalfeiertag mit einer informations
und leistungsschau zum gedenken an die
toten soldaten und opfer des widerstands
findet traditionell die
kranzniederlegung im raum und vor der
krypta des äußeren burgtor durch den
bundespräsidenten und die
bundesregierungen statt
auch die feierliche angelobung von über
1.300 rekruten am heldenplatz zieht jahr
für jahr mehr besucher an
[Applaus]
die eigentliche informations und
leistungsschau ist auch mehrere plätze
in der innenstadt aufgeteilt
hier können sich die zahlreichen
besucher hautnah ein bild von der
ausstattung aber auch den fähigkeiten
des bundesheeres machen
ich bin aus niederösterreich aber
studien liegen und ja und heute nicht am
heldenplatz und schaue mir an was das
bundesheer zu bieten hat und in
österreich ins geschützt
sie ist ja groß flächen aufgeteilt
eigentlich ein super programm den ganzen
tag überall ist hat und nachmittag hat
man vor gehört eine schau stellung auch
dani der streife und die hunde
und ich glaube das ist ein super
programm wo man eigentlich den ganzen
tag den ganzen nationalfeiertag
eigentlich super verbringen kann
besonders beliebt unter den besuchern
sind wie immer die hubschrauber panzer
und andere heeres fahrzeuge möglichkeit
wahr sich das bundesheer mord für das
bundesheer haben nur die wahl entweder
katastrophen haben der wüstener sein
soll froh dass da sein und sonst wird
nur geschimpft der kostbar gehört
braucht keiner wozu brauchen wir
kampfpanzer wozu brauchen wir
bergungsfahrzeuge und da ist so gut dass
die bevölkerung ermöglicht was unsere
soldaten leisten
[Musik]
dass das seit zwei jahren wieder mehr
schwung bringen ist und das hat mich
dazu gebracht sich wieder für die miliz
beworben haben und ja wünsche auch sehr
gespannt auf diese quasi auf diese ganze
übungen die jetzt kommen werden
ja und zwar als sehr motivierend erst
wenn man mit den leuten redet auch mit
den soldaten mit den kameraden nur sagen
dass daraus ein positiver druck wieder
bei ihnen ist in der ganzen mannschaft
[Musik]